[Applaudissements]
les bombes étaient géniaux ces petits
bouts
[Musique]
j'adore ce soir emporté soumission à mon
niveau j'ai pris d'autres officiels est
aussi bon soir s'il fait beau on vous
dira concernant ce soir c'est un battant
c'est pas simplement du mot c'est qu'on
est encore en exemple en dari pour votre
sécurité parce que ça qui est important
pour nous on doit remporter le cancer
alors menacé trouver une date
le public possible qui s'apprête ce
week-end s'est pas encore
et oui et de ses coûts tout le monde
aime contre manifester etc
c'est pas le moment là je parle de ce
qu'on va faire mais il fallut vrai que
vous poussez votre chez vous
tranquillement avec vos voitures sans
problème notamment porté le concert on
vous fera savoir par tous les médias
qu'elles doivent être choisis quant à
son possible parce que pour l'instant on
peut pas le faire certes et c'est nous
qui se vendent et vous s'il avait envie
de montrer chez vous vous avez découvert
par les détient de concert est donné est
bienvenu pour l'instant elle sait pas
encore pour le temps m et à partir de
demain vous aurez des nouvelles
les gens qui ont des tickets garder vos
tickets
c'est une garantie
ces leçons possibles
[Applaudissements]
les yankees une solution sage on
trouvera une solution pour ça le passé
encore annuler va vous dire aujourd'hui
à quimper
mais on fera ce concert puisqu'on vous
battre et essayer de sortir avec lui fut
mariée elle s'attend à ce dernier un
paquet d'accident on voudrait pas que
les gens puissent contourner galère
parce que l'on va tourner démarre plus
tout ça alors on est désolé on fait de
posséder bagdad le plus vite possible
que pour faire ce concert lorsque je
voudrais en deuxième partie de nuit du
brouillard et de pluie
donc c'est très attentionné j'y suis
formation et messieurs resca les côtes
sud est et suivi de cession mais on
demande juste une chose pour
partitionner cependant naby soumah
en six ans entre le conte ici
à présent possible de bruit possible
pour garçons observe m vous pourrez y
aura problème
je suis désolé si j'ai pu offenser jour
[Musique]
comprend pigeons qui manquent mais on a
laissé désert et resterez vous
[Musique]